your daddy I'm your daddy daddy is a
state of mind you're quoting me I've
been really impressed almost the fact
that I didn't turn into a monster
you see so much as twitches
okay this is the Game of Thrones reunion
we love without ever having actually
interacted on the show but
ify your bond at all how did you guys
bond to stolen Ellie we did talk about
it a little bit didn't we it was an
unspoken Bond I was curious because
poor Bella was it was it was in
different elements yes and a different
kind of con yeah different costume
um I had like a I had a flowy robe I
didn't have a wig and I got to be I was
in indoors in Belfast but outdoors in
Croatia
essentially a dream yeah it was a bit of
a dream
a big in and out for me yes
but we that was like an inspect that was
a thing we talked about it because I
watched the show before I got the job
and I continued watching it after I got
it so I got to meet and fall in love
with Lady Mormon in the way that
everyone else did and so to know that I
it definitely
um Bella uh was Ellie before I was Joel
and so it was so exciting for me to know
that I was gonna be with them on this
journey it's probably the best game of
all time came out in 2013 people are
always talking about it year after year
um did you play it when did you play it
were you told to stay away from it
we were advised encouraged during orders
to stay away from it uh we disobeyed
those orders and we did do our like we
didn't know that the other had been told
to to not watch it so we had a little
moment being like hey did you did you
like research it at all
um
yeah we each is our own individual like
research but I I'd heard of the game
it's like one of the only games I'd
heard of apart from like Call of Duty
and fortnite
um and yeah so it was something that was
like immediately exciting to me just
because of like the content of it and
the story and yeah yeah and he became
very very
clear very quickly how much people loved
it the games and the experience of
playing the game and that was scary and
uh because I guess you know you can get
really you can get into you can get
really into a book get really into a
series and this is the next level of
really getting into something by ex like
an immersive experience of playing these
characters
um and so people's relationship to that
experience is a deep one and we want and
we we want to kind of expand on that uh
meet expectations uh uh surpass
expectations learn something new show
something new
um and and also
you know honor what is originally there
and um
we're exhausted
you um are constantly you get this like
cargo and you're like I don't want to be
here and then you love them and you
build a bond with them and you are just
our daddy
your daddy I'm your daddy daddy is the
state of mind you're quoting me senior
interviews I don't I refuse to watch
them
um the uh yeah I guess I'm nothing like
that it's like leave me alone
I'll be here forever we've talked about
zotty and the difference between Daddy
and Daddy and Joel is his daddy daddy is
and what that's remind me zaddy's
brother
excuse me it's an older daddy excuse me
you saw in peppers
that's not setting
is that he's not older sexy sexy I know
sexier and older daddy is not like zaddy
is not um the Z is not for there's
nothing
about old that starts with the letter z
you know what I'll take it I'm not
offended I did not think I was gonna get
an argument with Pedro Pascal today but
here we are our first time I'm already
older Daddy what I've been being I've
been a daddy for a couple of years I'm
already older Dad yeah I don't even have
any kids
we're all your kids yeah it's true
you're all my that's how I got old so
fast
too much I'm gonna go die I will see you
guys later thank you please don't die
I'm yours Daddy thank you thanks Tom
don't do that to your daddy what
happened there okay love you guys love
you bye
[Music]